The 2020 election has shown just how
profoundly education politics have
shifted. For decades, Republicans used
education to demonstrate compassion and
signal the sincerity of their commitment
to equal opportunity. Democrats used
education to show that they were more
interested in offering a hand up than in
handouts. Today, neither side is all that
concerned about assuaging the middle or
signaling pragmatism. Education is now
playing an amped-up role in primary
campaigns. In 2016, Donald Trump hammered
Jeb Bush with the Common Core. In 2020,
Trump has energetically embraced school
vouchers and used them to draw a sharp
contrast with Democrats. In the
Democratic primary, candidates have raced
to one-up each other on free college,
loan forgiveness, and teacher pay. Whether
Trump or a Democrat claims the White
House in 2020, it's clear that the winner
will be less inclined to compromise and
more likely to stick with the more
partisan playbook. Welcome to education's new normal.
Do you think education
will be a big issue in the 2020 election?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.